Guten Morgen Linos.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Hast du mal Lust wieder auf kleine Weltraumreise.
Bei der netzpolitischen Tageslage bietet sich das an.
Logbuch Netzpolitik hunderteinundneunzig, eure intergalaktische Show aus dem Netzpolitischen Geschehen. Aber jetzt gibt's neue äh Fluchtmöglichkeiten im Berlin-Prenzlauer Berg.
Kann man endlich von diesem Planeten runter.
Na ja, na ja, zumindest man kann so tun als ob ich war nämlich gestern bei einer äh Eröffnung mit äh mit allerlei Prominenz.
Na ja, also der Bürgermeister und noch so ein paar andere Handels, die gerne gewählt werden möchten und Sigmund Jähn war da,
ganze bei der Eröffnung des des Planetariums, das zeis Großplante-Haus, moder.
Ist das schon längst offen.
Ja seit gestern Abend.
Nochmal neue offen jetzt, ne? Die haben irgendwie geupdatet oder was.
Die haben äh schwer geupdatet, die haben das Ding einfach mal komplett entkernt, alles rausgerissen und alles äh komplett neu gebaut.
Hattest du auch schon mal so eine Folge zu, wo der das erzählt hat, wie.
Erzählten angekündigt hat und das hat jetzt stattgefunden. Und jetzt habe ich da gestern gesessen und mir mal so die Technik angeschaut und es ist so,
yes. Kann ich nur sehr empfehlen. Also äh was so früher,
so diese siebenundachtziger DDR-Technik war mit Diaprojektoren und schon im ganz ordentlichen Sternprojektor,
ist jetzt äh so richtig nice. Und ich hab mich dann noch so mit den Nerds von von Zeiss unterhalten, die irgendwie.
Deren deren der Stolz über diesen Sternprojektor, den sie da reingesetzt haben, wirklich aus allen Poren freundlich. Unglaublich, aber ist auch echt geile Techniken muss man sagen. Also was für einen Aufwand da.
Irgendwie so riesige Rennerfarben, um Alpha sich durch diese Weltraum bewegen zu können.
Es gibt halt zwei Dinge, es gibt den digitalen Teil, das machen die halt mit Beamern, da hast du halt so acht K Mal acht K.
Das ist schon viele Pixel so, aber damit kriegst du natürlich nicht die Auflösung hin, die du für den Sternenhimmel brauchst, deswegen gibt's halt in der Mitte ganz klassisch noch so ein Sternenprojektor,
aber eben der so das neueste und tollste, was äh so derzeit auf diesem Planeten zu holen ist, so der erste mit LED-Licht und und so weiter mit einem unfassbaren Aufwand, ein Sternprojekter, der irgendwie neuntausendeinhundert Sterne macht, das Geile ist,
jeder einzelne kann funkeln, unabhängig von den anderen,
sieht so cool aus, das sieht so cool aus. Ich habe mir dabei erklären lassen, wie die, wie die das irgendwie gemacht haben und die sind einfach stolz geplatzt also,
Ja und Japaner, die haben ja behauptet, die könnten das auch, aber ich habe mir das dann angeguckt und da bei denen funkeln nur einundzwanzig Sterne bei uns funkeln alle neuntausendeinhundert,
Und es sieht richtig geil aus. Also sitzt da so drin, denkst du oder so, okay, alles klar, habt ihr jetzt gerade das Dach abgemacht oder was? Schon echt cool,
Ja, das äh geht jetzt los. Ja und dieser ganze digitale äh Klimbim ist natürlich geil. Wenn da nicht irgendwie das Wittos wäre, auf dem das alles läuft, das äh.
Also kam zwischendurch Update.
Das wird das würde sogar so schlimm ist es nicht, aber.
Und dann sehen sie hier bring bring ein sorry das Mything Conven.
Der Chef musste schon in der Eröffnungsrede darauf hinweisen, dass wenn es hier Probleme gibt, dann liegt es an, wenn du es hat er mir nicht gesagt,
Das ist so großartig. Beziehungsweise ist natürlich nicht so großartig, aber leider kommt halt so diese Planetariumsoftware, die State of die Art sie gehört halt Microsoft gerade.
So ist das. Da gibt's noch nicht die passenden Open Source Alternativen, mit denen man mal eben so.
System, die brauchen wir noch.
Aber da kann man dann sozusagen sich äh äh vollkommen befreit vom Netzpolitischen Gefühl so ein bisschen den Stern hingeben und träumen, als wenn man das drin haut. Ja.
Aber dann ist dieses Show vorbei, dann.
Und dann kommt ein neues Terrorpaket. Antiterrorpaket.
Genau, dann schlägt, schlägt man seine Webseiten auf und äh denkt sich nur so, oh man habt ihr nichts besseres zu tun im Sommer.
Ja, was denn passiert? Also es äh gibt mal wieder neue Forderungen. Wir haben ja über die eine oder andere auch schon berichtet. Aber bevor wir dazu kommen.
Blicken wir zunächst einmal zu den Hackerse. Die Hacker. Die Hacker so.
Die Hacker, die Hacker haben gehackt.
Ich weiß nicht, das war jetzt ein sehr großes Thema diese Woche, viele äh Spekulationen zu. Und zwar hat äh irgendeine Gruppe äh wo viel spekuliert wird, wer es denn sein mag, eine ein,
Dampf veröffentlicht, also es war glaube ich ursprünglich auf Githab und auf,
Tumbler, dort aber innerhalb kürzester Zeit dann auch nicht mehr zu finden. Äh,
irgendwie in so Witz schlechtem Englisch, We lookweehack, NSA, hier Data, ja. Und es war eine äh eine Datei, die man,
Eine komprimierte Datei, die man entschlüsseln konnte und eine, die man noch nicht entschlüsseln,
kann, weil der Kiel nicht äh oder das Passwort nicht dazu gegeben wurde ähm und indem dass die kleinere zweihundert noch was MB war quasi die Kostprobe und auf die größere Solle dann eine Bitcoin-Auktion bitte stattfinden.
Auktion. Ich dachte, wir halten dann einen Festpreis.
Ja ihr, also
kommen wir gleich zu. Ähm ich habe mir dann mal diese kleinere Datei angeschaut beziehungsweise anfangs habe ich mir nur einen Auszug der kleineren Datei angeschaut, weil irgendeiner meinte, hier
sind die Daten nur die Hälfte rausgeben zu müssen, das habe ich dann anfangs etwas verwirrt in meinen Recherchen. Äh aber ich habe dann nachher äh gefunden, wo es den den vollen Dampf gibt und da sind also eine Reihe an.
Tja, wie soll man das sagen? Also Exploid Tools,
Anleitung und Command and Control Sachen so eine Reihe an ähm also ein Einbruchswerkzeugkoffer
wo dann irgendwie so Sachen drinstehen wie äh
wie man also ein bestimmtes Exploid anwendet oder wie man einen bestimmten Angriff durchführt so ein bisschen runtergeschrieben so typisch
Software im Flow, jetzt irgendwie kein Shiny Manuel, sondern so eine TXT Datei, wo drin steht hier, machst du so, machst du so. Achtung, nicht so machen,
Vorsicht, achte darauf, den dritten Parameter auch wirklich anzugeben, sonst funktioniert das nicht so. Und da war halt allerlei ähm.
Allerlei Kram dann eben dabei und es wurde gesagt, ja das äh wäre also jetzt der der Angriffswerkzeugkoffer der NSA oder Teile des äh Angriffswerkzeugkoffers der NSA.
Und es gab ja schon vorher einige ähm Recherchen zu äh,
Quasi den der Hacking Unit, der NSA. Ähm die von Kaspersky in der Veröffentlichung vor ein, zwei Jahren äh Equation Group getauft wurde,
wenn ich mich recht entsinne im Bezug darauf, dass die ähm.
Glaube ich sehr relativ viel Krypto machen oder sowas. Also sehen wir, ich weiß nicht mehr genau aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen haben sie sie Equation Group genannt, also Gleichungsgruppe, mathematische Gleichungsgruppe,
Und ähm.
Es sah hier oder es sieht hier danach aus, dass das eben, dass das, was hier veröffentlicht wurde, eben Tools sind, die auch von dieser Gruppe
stammen. Äh Kasperski hat das insbesondere dadurch bestätigt, dass die in ihren äh Command Control Traffic, glaube ich, ähm von einer bestimmten, relativ seltenen,
Implementierung von RC fünf oder so Gebrauch machen und dies findet man relativ selten oder die war wohl handgeschrieben und die hat man da jetzt auch wieder gefunden, was irgendwie den Eindruck vermittelt
dass das vor den gleichen Programmierern stammt. Und insgesamt ist dieses Paket also bisschen zu.
Umfänglich, als dass man jetzt davon ausgehen könnte, dass es sich dabei um eine Fälschung handelt. Das war schon relativ früh klar. Ähm,
Die Exploids, die dabei waren, also Explored heißt es gibt Maschine steht da, Computer, steht da, Gerät steht da.
Kurt zum Ausnutzen von Sicherheitslücken.
Genau, hat eine Sicherheitslücke, da musst du ja immer noch etwas schreiben, was diese Sicherheitslücke ausnutzt in deinem Sinne. Das ist dann der Unterschied zwischen Sicherheitslücke und Exploid. Und da gab's jetzt schöne Exploids drin,
Ähm und die richteten sich hauptsächlich gegen ähm Firewalls irgendwie also Juniper Cisco, Watchgard, solche Geschichten, also äh
Switches, die du dir halt kaufst, dann ist das Franzisku und dann kostet das viel Geld und dann dann steht das in deinem Rechenzentrum und dann kommt die NSA und hackt dir das Ding,
Und das ist natürlich äh gefährlich, weil wenn sie das dann schaffen, dein äh deine Firewall oder deine Route, da
zu übernehmen, dann können sie natürlich entsprechende Routen erlauben, Regeln ändern und so ähm weiter in deinem Netzwerk
rumhacken, ja? Also wenn du während du vielleicht normalerweise deine Firewall da steht und dafür sorgt, dass äh.
Das keine Ahnung, die ganzen Wald Rebilitys deiner Windows Kisten nicht eben nicht offen im Netz hängen, kannst du halt dann hingehen und sagen, ach so ja hier und da machen wir mal eine Route, erlaube mal diesen Traffic äh und locke den mal nicht mit, sodass wir hier schön weiter,
in das Netz vordringen können, dass unsere unser Hintereingang sich schön ausbaut. Und solche Sach.
Sitzt dann sozusagen im Büro des äh des Sicherheitspersonals und hast alle Knöpfchen um die Türen auf und zu.
Zum Beispiel oder einer Infrastruktur oder so, ne? Also, wenn du die Firewall geound hast, bist du auf jeden Fall schon mal ein sehr, sehr großen Schritt weiter. Und.
Diese diese Exploids, die da drin waren, bezogen sich auf teilweise auch.
Auf ältere Versionen irgendwie so bei Cisco war's dann irgendwie Version vier äh acht Punkt eins bis acht Punkt vier oder sowas. Inzwischen sind die aber bei Version neun, aber dann Updaten natürlich nicht alle ihre Systeme die ganze Zeit,
Und der Stand dieser dieser ganzen Sachen war laut Datum, was da drin stand. Jetzt weiß man natürlich nicht, ob die Daten, ob die Time Stance der Dateien auch wirklich stimmen.
Aber auch so vom von der Softwarelage her, von den war das alles also zwanzig dreizehn. Also ziemlich genau,
Zu Edward Snowdenzeit. Und seitdem nichts mehr. Und jetzt war natürlich
kam dann die Frage, okay, das gibt's jetzt da, dann hat es ein bisschen gedauert, gerade weil das eben relativ spezifische äh Switches waren, die jetzt auch nicht jeder zu Hause einfach mal so rumstehen hat, wenn du das handelt sich da eben um teure Geräte, die hast du im Wände, die besitzt, hast du dir auch irgendwo produktiv im Einsatz
ja? Die meisten zumindest.
Und da muss ja auch noch diese spezifischen Softwareversionen finden und so. Das heißt, das hat dann noch ein bisschen gedauert, bis äh Forscher und äh ich glaube auch Cisco selber dann eben
So ein Ding war isoliert hingestellt, haben die Exploids drauf geschossen haben und geguckt haben, was machen die denn.
Geht das überhaupt.
Genau, funktioniert das oder war hat da einer einfach nur was Spannendes geschrieben, was aussieht wie ein Export und stellte sich raus, die funktionieren auch alle. Und ähm.
Da waren dann auch so so lustige Sachen wie das du auf eine auf ein VPN Punkt.
Pakete Virs und da ein Overflow erzeugst und dann antwortet der dir mit Speicherinhalten,
Wenn das lange genug machst, dann hast du halt den den Key von der Fire äh von der Entschuldigung, von der Firewall. Von dem VPN und kannst dann äh dieses VPN abhören. Das ist natürlich schon äh relativ
ärgerlich, wenn äh Leute sagen, hier äh wir bauen unsere ganze Sicherheit auf so einen Cisco IP-Sect VPN auf und dann kommt die NSA und holt sich die Kies dazu, das ist natürlich dann,
nicht im im Sinne der Betreiber. Also krasses Zeug ähm und,
Jetzt viel spannender, aber natürlich die Frage, wer hat das woher? Und warum wird es jetzt veröffentlicht? Warum nicht vor drei Jahren,
Ähm und dann gibt's also mehrere Theorien, so die,
Die Angreifer selber sagen ja, wir haben die NSA gehackt und haben die Sachen da rausgeholt. Ursprünglich haben einige so die Theorie verbreitet, ja, es kann ja gut sein, dass ähm ein,
Ein Hacker der NSL, das auf einem Zielsystem hat, liegen lassen.
Das halte ich aber für eine etwas schwache Theorie, weil eben die Exploid-Tools dabei sind und nicht nur die Implants, die du am Ende dann damit anbringst, ja? Das heiß.
Meine mit dem ganzen Exklärungen, das ist nicht unbedingt das, was man jetzt äh.
Das ist nicht das, was du irgendwo, was du irgendwo auf deinem Opferrechner rumliegen hast. Und das würdest du also,
Es gäbe jetzt du müsstest sehr unvorsichtig sein, um so etwas auf einer auf einer anderen Kiste irgendwie liegen zu lassen. Ja, also zum Beispiel du kannst ja selbst wenn du jetzt irgendwie einen Rechner
bei deinem Zielnetzwerk irgendwie geohnt hast, dann würdest du ja nicht diese Sachen da drauf kopieren, sondern du würdest immer deine Kommandos halt in den,
reinkopieren, ja? Also und direkt ausführen. Insofern schwierig davon auszugehen, dass das
dass irgendein unvorsichtiger NSA-Hacker das irgendwo hat liegenlassen. Ausgeschlossen ist es nicht, aber.
Der müsste schon sehr blöd sein.
Ja, also der hätte auf jeden Fall jetzt ein.
Ein Problem. Die zweite Theorie ist ja für ich meine, wenn die NSA heckt rum, viele andere äh
Staaten hacken auch rum. Vielleicht hat es wirklich jemand geschafft äh früher oder später irgendwie diese NSA mal zu hacken und die Daten bei denen,
rauszutragen. Da wird natürlich dann gesagt, ja, man würde jetzt ja schon davon ausgehen, dass die NSA ihre Angriffsrechner irgendwie entsprechend stark ähm,
Unter Kontrolle hält, ja? Und dass es sich schwierig gestalten sollte, die an diese Daten zu kommen. Gut.
Das ist sicherlich nicht einfach, die NSA zu hacken, aber wir gehen mal davon aus, dass die NSA nicht die einzige Gruppe auf der Welt ist, die hacken kann. Insofern kann es sehr gut sein, dass äh vermutlich ein anderer, die die Hackergruppe eines anderen Staates dann da auch mal
die Gelegenheit ergriffen hat ähm zuzugreifen.
Und die dritte Theorie, die so zirkuliert wird, ist eben, dass einfach irgendein NSA-Mitarbeiter oder ehemaliger NSA-Mitarbeiter mit einem USB-Stick rausmarschiert ist und die Sachen,
gedammt hat, ja. Und im Prinzip einfach der NSA schaden möchte oder so. Ähm, das also die drei.
Die drei Theorien, wie jemand an diese Daten gekommen ist, alle.
Schaden in Anführungsstrichen, in Hinblick auf die Forderung ähm gibt uns Bitcoin, dann kriegt ihr mehr äh.
Ja genau, jetzt.
Noch eine andere Motivation als nur Schaden.
Die sind ja veröffentlicht, ne? Also die die größere Teil ist ja normal oder der der kleine kleinere Teil davon ist veröffentlicht, insbesondere hier diese Firewall Exploids und ähm da ist schon durch die Veröffentlichung,
hoffentlich einiger Schaden entstanden, wobei man natürlich sagen muss, alles stand zwanzig dreizehn. Und da kommen wir nämlich jetzt zu der Überlegung,
Warum die Veröffentlichung jetzt.
Und warum überhaupt die Veröffentlichung? Hm, es gibt ja verschiedene Gründe, also wenn wir jetzt mal davon ausgehen, du bist jetzt ein.
Final Staat nicht besonders,
NS von der NSA oder ein eins Staat, der auch Angriffsziele der NSA ist. Russland, China oder so, ne? Die werden mit Sicherheit von der NSA angegriffen. Und du hast jetzt Wissen.
Deutschland.
Ja wir ja sowieso, aber wir werden ja nicht angegriffen, wir geben das ja freiwillig her, ja? Das ist ja
Kennst du das irgendwie Überfall auf auf offener Straße, wovor der Typ die Pistole zieht, Handy, Portemonnaie kommt, lass mir in Ruhe gehen. So ist, so ist Deutschland. Wir fangen also,
Und jetzt jetzt äh hast du halt Wissen darüber. Das wäre ja schon spannend. Du hast auf einmal ein zu einem.
Ein Wissen darüber, wie dieser Gegner agiert. Du kennst dessen Exploids. Du hast den selber gehackt, du weißt, was der rummacht. Dann würdest du ja eigentlich.
Den das nicht wissen lassen, weil wenn du den das wissen lässt, macht der irgendwie das nächste oder so, ne? Das heißt, eigentlich würdest du dem gerne.
Simulieren, dass du nicht merkst, dass deine Infrastruktur kompromitiert ist,
wie durch Zufall daran hindern wirklich seine Ziele zu erreichen.
Also selber patchen, aber.
Du siehst, was er macht, äh damit du erkennst, welches Angreiferwissen er hat und dann im Zweifelsfall mit sowas wie einem,
Geheimdienst oder im Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik nach und nach dafür sorgst, dass der
dass diese Angriffe isoliert werden, der damit nicht durchkommt, ne? Und den aber gleichzeitig im Auge behalten, was er danach macht und möglichst viel Wissen über dessen Fähigkeiten erlangen.
Aufsetzen, dass man einfach so tut, als wäre da jetzt auf einmal was äh Interessantes und da ist halt eigentlich gar nichts Interessantes, aber man kann halt den Angreifer beobachten, während er da drin herumschnor.
Genau, so würde ich mir das vorstellen, wenn ich jetzt wirklich mit äh mit massigem Budget als staatlicher Aktor Akteur da bin und Cyber-Krieg spiele, ne? Dann würde ich das so machen.
Also kann man eigentlich fast ausschließen, dass das hier sozusagen die anderen fremden Mächte TM sind.
Na warte, darfst ja nicht vergessen, die Dinger sind drei Jahre alt und die Theorie, die Snowden entfaltet ist.
Waren wahrscheinlich die Russen und,
er wirre begründet das mit dieser typischen, die russischen, die Russen spielen ja Schach und die Amerikaner spielen ja Poker, ne? Das war ja schon zum Kaltkrieg so. Ähm das hat er jetzt nicht gesagt, aber so so kann's dir das ja immer vorstellen. Und er,
Er sagt, okay, die Russen.
Wurden ja jetzt beschuldigt, dass sie an diesem DNC League äh ihre Finger im Spiel hatten. Äh diese Demokratik National Council, wo also diese ganzen Internen E-Mails der demokratischen US-Partei äh,
gelegt wurden. Und Snowden sagt, na ja, weil die Amerikaner jetzt quasi sagen, hier, das waren die Russen, das waren die Russen,
Demonstrieren die Russen mit diesem League einfach mal übrigens,
Vorsicht, wenn ihr wirklich das Spiel spielen wollt, wer hinter welchem Heck steht, zu beweisen,
also wirklich zu sagen, hier, wir haben Beweise, dass der und der das war, dann könnte das sehr unangenehm für euch werden, weil wir eure Angriffstools kennen. Und wenn wir die jetzt alle veröffentlichen.
Dann können eine ganze Menge Firmen und Unternehmen und Staaten, die gehackt wurden, feststellen, dass sie auf diese Weise gehackt wurden und erfahren, dass sie ein Ziel von euch waren.
Und das würde für euch diplomatisch im Zweifelsfall das ein oder andere Problem ergeben.
Ja gut, aber das Problem haben sie ja nun sowieso schon seit Dienstveröffentlichung und niemand geht mehr von irgendetwas anderem aus. Ich glaube, meine nicht, dass jetzt diese Sammlung an Tools da jetzt sehr viel ändert.
Als der Bundestag gehackt wurde, haben sie sofort wieder mit dem Finger nach Russland gezeigt, ne.
Ja gut aber das würden sie dann im Zweifelsfall auch trotzdem wieder tun. Ganz unabhängig von diesen Veröffentlichungen.
Ne, ich weiß es nicht. Also ein die Frage ist, eigentlich ist es als wäre eigentlich unklug, diese Daten zu veröffentlichen.
Solange man ein äh Nation State Actor ist, aber es kann unter Umständen interessant sein,
das zu tun, wenn es sich um drei Jahre alter handelt. Einfach nur um mal kurz zu sagen, hier übrigens, wir haben.
Das seit, wir haben das vor drei Jahren schon, wir haben euch schon vor drei Jahren gehackt, ne? Und wir können alles, was ihr seitdem gemacht habt oder bis dahin gemacht habt, habt Atribuieren. Ich weiß es nicht, was die, was wirklich die ähm,
Die Motivation dahinter ist,
Aber es kann halt unter Umständen halt mal gut ins Spiel passen. Eigentlich würde ich grundsätzlich sagen, du möchtest nicht, dass dein Gegner etwas über deine Fähigkeiten weiß, aber aus dieser ganzen
kalten Kriegsgeschichte kennt man, dass ja, dass sie sich dann immer mal wieder aus Versehen
beim Transport von riesigen Atomraketen haben filmen lassen, nur mal kurz zu zeigen so, wir wollten ja eigentlich nicht, dass ihr das wisst, aber guck mal, was wir hier für eine, was wir hier für eine schöne Rakete haben, ne? Nordkorea hat ja auch gerade wieder vom U-Boot irgendwas hochgeschossen
nur um mal der Welt zu demonstrieren hier, ne? Wenn,
können mit dem Ubo zu euch fahren und euch irgendwie ein Atomei auf den Kopf werfen, wenn wir, wenn wir zu lange Fernsehen geguckt haben.
Bauer H fünf.
Was ist das?
Bauer H fünf. Tja. Ja, du ziehst halt den schwarzen Bauern auf H fünf, so zwei vor.
Und man fragt sich, hä? Was machst du mit deinem scheiß Bauern da? Warum ziehst du den zwei vor.
Dann fängt man an nachzudenken so. War das jetzt ein schlichter Zug oder will er mich da jetzt irgendwie reinlegen oder planen die irgendwas oder auf einmal ist so eine kleine Verunsicherung im Spiel.
Das scheint da jetzt die ähm die Sache zu sein. Jetzt jetzt kommen wir zu dieser ähm.
Jetzt kommen wir zu dieser Auktion. Und zwar haben wir, wie ist das Modell? Die haben gesagt, wir möchten gerne so und so viel Bitcoin dafür haben, dass wir den Rest veröffentlichen oder das Passwort von dem Rest oder dem Bieter das geben, ne.
Ich habe irgendwas von einer Million Bitcoin gelesen, aber ich weiß jetzt oder hundert.
Also irgend so eine völlig.
Kein Ende vollkommen irre Zahl auf jeden Fall.
Wo ich jetzt gar nicht mal glaube, dass na ja okay, man weiß ja Geier. Also ich meine, dass solche Explorts haben natürlich einen Marktwert äh in gewisser Hinsicht haben sie hier auch schon gezeigt,
Erstens, das ist jetzt nicht irgendwas, das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie eine Linux-Schwäche oder so, sondern wir haben's hier unter anderem mit,
Fehlern in Cisco und anderen Enterprise Greate Systemen zu tun, die potentiell einfach bei Firmenunternehmen, Organisationen größerer Natur aller Art zu finden sind und,
Die sagen wir mal wertvoller sind als jetzt irgend so ein exotisches irgendwie ich,
auf deinem Gin Two System so, was irgendwie ein paar Leute verwenden.
Dass es Infrastruktur, ne.
Ja und das ist so auch das, worauf man dann eben auch leicht trifft, weil es einfach massenhaft im Einsatz ist. Teilweise waren's ja auch, ich weiß nicht,
waren das, also ich habe jetzt gelesen von unter anderem, ich weiß nicht, ob nicht, ob es nur so war, alte Hardware, die Franzisko so gar nicht mehr verkauft wird, also ich glaube, dieser VPN-Haber, der ist so gar nicht mehr im Verkauf, aber natürlich noch in der Nutzung.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie sich darauf beschränkt hat oder ob das jetzt nur unter anderem so war.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall ist es wertvoll so potenziell und äh sicherlich auch sein Geld wert auf dem Markt.
Äh
Aber dann gibt es hier eigentlich auch ganz andere Kreise, in denen man solche Explores anbietet, nicht unbedingt jetzt mit so einer Aktion.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall irgendwie so crazy, ne?
Ich würde jetzt auch nicht so viel Geld für ein paar NSA Explods bezahlen, weil die gegen die Amerikaner kann ich die schon mal nicht zum Einsatz bringen
ja? Die werden ja dagegen alle Immun sein. Und ähm ich mein's, was auch sein könnte ist.
Aber amerikanische Unternehmen sind natürlich davon betroffen.
Na, wer weiß? Was, also was natürlich auch sein könnte, ist das, was sie jetzt free released haben, ist alles, was sie haben,
Und dieser andere restliche Dampf, den sie da zu utopischen Preisen veröffentlichen, ist einfach irgendwie ein Backup von Def äh Random und ähm
wenn und sie wissen, dass niemand darauf äh
Dass niemand das ersteigern wird, also wird's nie veröffentlicht, aber die NSA sitzt jetzt da und muss zittern, ob ihre Daten da drin sind oder nicht,
Also es gibt viele viele Theorien, aber es es macht alles nicht so richtig
nicht so richtig Sinn aus, also so irgendwie auch wenn die Typen jetzt ernsthaft, ja, wer ernsthaft das Geld jetzt versteigert, ja, dieses Bitcoin Wallet, mit dem kannst du ja nichts mehr anfangen.
Ich meine, wenn du wenn du wenn du die Exploids der NSA liegst und dann auch noch,
kaufst, ja für irgendwie weiß nicht wie viel Millionen, ja? Und diese Bitcoin kassierst, ja
dann glaubst du nicht im Ernst, dass du auch nur ein Bitcoin davon ausgeben kannst, ohne dass die irgendwie mit einem Todesschwadron kommen und deine Stadt in Schutt und Asche legen.
Also ich meine, wenn du wenn du wenn du das gemacht hast, ja, dann kannst du jetzt eigentlich nur noch,
aller elektronischen Geräte entledigen, die du hast und irgendwie.
Eine Höhle in Afghanistan beziehen, ja.
Eine Höhle beziehen und ein paar Apfelbäume pflegen oder so. Aber viel mehr bleibt dir nicht mehr als Option. Es sei denn, du hast irgendwie natürlich äh Nation State Actor äh Power hinter dir. Ja? Das also Putin sagt,
A hast du gehackt? Ja, mach mal hier, cool, Hecken, ha. Äh Witze, schön wohnen,
Ne, das könnte halt das könnte ich wie alt so vorstellen, dass das halt,
Also wenn das jetzt irgendeine Crew von von offensichtlich sehr begabten Leuten ist, die das irgendwie witzig meinen und am Ende auch glauben, dass sie diese Bitcoins einsacken und dann sich auf Silko davon Ecstasy kaufen können. Den würde ich davon abraten.
Was sind denn so die aktuellen Erkenntnisse, um wen es sich denn jetzt bei der Equation Group wiederum handelt? Also Shadow Brokers haben wir jetzt sozusagen den den Angreifer in diesem Szenario haben wir jetzt ausreichend äh herumgerätelt,
aber auch die Identität dieser Equation Group ist ja so auch nicht bestätigt. Also es gibt die Behauptung es handelt sich um die NSA.
Also da kann man, glaube ich, ähm da ist, glaube ich, jeder Zweifel weg. Vor allem, weil ich glaube, der Washington Post gegenüber irgendwelche ehemaligen NSA-Mitarbeiter gesagt haben,
Was da passiert ist, ist richtig Kacke und wir werden jetzt mal bei uns in den Rhein gucken, wer das war,
Also die haben schon ich glaube so von der Nachrichtenlage, die ich jetzt so überblicke und von der,
Faktenlage gibt's eigentlich niemanden, der daran zweifelt, dass das von der NSA ist.
Ja, ich habe jetzt auch gelesen, dass es dann auch konkret vielleicht diese TAO, diese T-Light Exis Group sein kann, die ja.
Taylor Excess Operations.
Täter, ja, richtig äh Operation. Also die der Teil, der sich sozusagen mit spezifischen Attacken auf bestimmte Ziele, auf bestimmte,
Personen äh beschäftigt. Da gab's ja auch einen Vortrag, glaube ich, vor zwei Jahren auf dem Kongress zu dem Thema,
wo halt die ganzen auch vorgestellt wurden und das wurde schon äh bemerkenswert, nicht? Äh hier so Sachen mit, du kochst ein Roter bei Amazon und dann kriegst du ihn sozusagen schon,
äh von Amazon schon die gebackt zugeschickt und äh solche Maßnahmen.
Passt insofern äh ganz gut ins Bild, aber ich glaube, sehr viel mehr können wir dann jetzt zu nichts zu sagen.
Ja, es ist ein ein lustiges Spiel zum Rumraten und dieser Auktion verläuft da, glaube ich, auch eher schleppend. So besonders viel Geld hat da keiner drauf geworfen.
Auch nochmal halbes Bitcoin.
Ne, habe ich noch nicht mal.
Ich verbrenne mir jetzt auch nicht einen Bitcoin-Wallet, indem ich also,
Weißt du auf dieses, auf dieses Wallet würde ich jetzt so sehr, sehr unter erhöhten Vorsichtsmaßnahmen irgendwie mal Geld werfen. Das ist äh.
Ja
Muss nicht.
So, so, der Linus kann sich also noch nicht mal ein NSA Exploid äh ach so, du hast schon welche. Na ja gut und das reicht ja auch, ja.
NSIXploids. Ja, sicher, du reicht doch hier gratis. Die Freeware-Variante reicht auch völlig.
Paar exklusive, weißt du, das ist doch so, äh wenn man sich einen geklauten Pfannkoch kauft, so, den stellt man dann so in seinen Safe und findet's geil. Da wird nie einer sehen, bis zum Toder.
Ja, ist auch so ein paar geile Bits auf der Platte.
Gibt's bestimmt auch, so Sammler Nerds.
Ja, natürlich gibt's Sammlerners, also wie Exploid-Sammler gibt's ohne Ende, die haben die nur im Zweifel selber äh gesucht, ne und selber gefunden.
Na gut. Kommen wir nach Berlin.
Ja, da die Berliner Erklärung hatten wir ja schon angesprochen in der letzten Sendung und angekündigt, dass das äh dass es das gibt,
und wir werden in der nächsten Folge Lokbuch Netzkritik das Ganze auch nochmal sehr viel genauer aufarbeiten und vertiefen. Deswegen äh setzen wir uns jetzt nun mit Teilen der ganzen IT,
Sicherheitsforderungen auseinander. Schön war äh IM, De Maisier, sagte dann der Bild am Sonntag,
Es gibt für Privatpersonen die Möglichkeit, jemanden zu fotografieren und mit einer Gesichtserkennungssoftware im Internet herauszufinden, ob es sich um einen prominenten oder einen Politiker handelt, den man gerade gesehen hat,
Ich möchte eine solche Gesichtserkennungssoftware an den Videokameras an Flughäfen und Bahnhöfen einsetzen.
Allerdings natürlich nicht zum Erkennen von Prominenten und Politikern, sondern zum Erkennen von äh von Terroristen, ne? Und Personen nach denen gefahndet wird.
Und jetzt streitet man sich darüber, ob ob das überhaupt erlaubt ist oder nicht,
Einige sagen, ja äh gar kein Thema hier, ne? Andere sagen, nee, ist Datenschutzrechtlich nicht okay. Und da muss man ja mal überlegen, wie würde denn so ein System funktionieren, ne? Du hast also überall deine Kameras, ja sagen wir mal irgendwie Berliner Hauptbahnhof äh,
Berliner Flughafen Tegel.
BER müsste es ja erstmal nochmal die ganzen Kabel für die Kameras ziehen, denn er hatte wahrscheinlich auch schon Kamera. Flughafenwitze müssen wir jetzt gar nicht machen eigentlich.
Einfach jede Eingangstür hat eine Kamera fe.
Hast du überall diese Kameras? So und jetzt laufen dann natürlich enorm viele Menschen durch. Und dann sagen wir, du hast so einen Pool aus äh,
Was ist das dann? Von mir aus zweihundert Gesichtern, nach denen du gerade fahren lässt, ne? Wo du gerade guckst, okay, wer ist das? So sagte,
gerade, ne? Also das ist ja das ist ja die, das, was er da gerade sagt, der will ja nicht jeden oder wahrscheinlich nicht jeden einzelnen erkennen, noch nicht. Das kommt ja erst danach, sondern wer nur Leute erkennen, nach den gefahrenet wird,
Jetzt musst du aber äh jedes Gesicht in diesem Bahnhof ja auf jeden Fall erfassen.
Der hat bestimmt nicht Leute gesagt hätte bestimmt Gefährder gesagt oder sowas.
Ich weiß es nicht genau, also sie gerade mal kurz um die,
Also Videostream, Leute laufen da die ganze Zeit durch. So, jetzt hast du, kommen da Gesichter, du hast auf der einen Seite eben die, weiß ich nicht, wie viel tausend Gesichter die da am Tag durchmarschieren und auf der anderen Seite deine paar Gesichter nach denen du suchst,
Und jetzt muss sie aber trotzdem jedes Gesicht, was da lang läuft,
Einmal mindestens verarbeiten und du willst es ja auch nicht zweimal verarbeiten. Das heißt, du behälst die Daten über das Gesicht,
ne? Also wenn der die Person, die an der Eingangstür einmal durchgelaufen ist und dann hinten zur Toilette geht und da nochmal gefilmt wird, die wird's ja nicht nochmal ein zweites Mal vergleichen, sondern die hast du ja identifiziert als Nichtgefährder.
Also trackst du schon mal die Person, wie sie sich in dem Gebäude bewegen.
Und jetzt stell dir vor die gleiche Person geht aber dann nochmal äh kommt jetzt fährt irgendwie durch ein Nicht-Video überwachtes Gebiet und kommt auf einmal dann eben am,
Bahnhof wieder raus oder so, ne? Wenn wir jetzt die Frage scannst du die nochmal oder wiedererkennst du die?
Dein System funktioniert natürlich besser, wenn du die wieder erkennst, statt nochmal den Vergleich zu machen.
Und je mehr du quasi von den je mehr du die Bewegung der Leute trackst und einmal identifizierte Gesichter nicht nochmal neu identifizierst.
Umso besser funktioniert das System. Besser, umso besser skaliert das, weil sonst bist du ja die ganze Zeit immer wieder, wenn das jetzt am Nesttisch wäre, dieses System, dann will es ja andauernd immer wieder vergessen, was es schon einmal verglichen und berechnet hat. Also lässt du das Ding sich die Sachen merken.
Und dann ist es am Ende einfacher, das nicht mehr nur mit den zweihundert Leuten, die du suchst, abzugleichen, sondern von vornherein einfach einmal mit allen.
Mit allen.
Gesichtern, die du hast mit allen, mit allen, die du kennst, mit allen Biometrischen Daten, die du ja nicht gesammelt hast beim Anlegen des äh Biomer.
Ja, ja.
Und des Reisepasses. Die sind ja nicht. So kämen wir denn dahin, wenn wir das speichern würden. Und.
Das ist klar, das das heißt diese Daten liegen vor, man hat biometrische Informationen über jeden Bürger dieses Landes.
Ist dir auch scheißegal, selbst wenn du die nicht hast, dann holst du dir halt, wenn die äh holt sie immer am Flughafen, wenn die durch die äh Schleuse gehen und ihren Pasta halt, also die,
Pässe auf die auf die Dinge zu halten, steht oben nochmal eine Kamera und dann steht da, ich sehe ein Gesicht,
Was sagt das Passlesegerät? Ah, Linus Neumann, wunderbar, haben wir uns jetzt mal gemerkt und haben den für den Rest des äh für den Rest der Zeit hier. Das heißt, am Ende hättest du einen relativ bald.
Ein System, was einfach die Bewegung von allen Menschen die ganze Zeit im im öffentlichen Raum trackt.
Ja und also ich meine These ist,
Es muss umzufunktionieren, muss es auch einfach alle tracken, weil es am Ende weniger rechen aufwendig ist, Leute wiederzuerkennen als jedes Mal zu gucken, gescannt ist kein Terrorist, ich vergesse die Daten,
Weil das war ja die Datenschutz ähm die Datenschutz ähm freundliche Variante, dass jedes Mal, wenn du in eine Kamera reinläufst.
Ja aber warum sollte denn die Kamera nicht jedes Mal prüfen? Ich meine, das ist ja nun nicht so der große Aufwand heutzutage. Du hast hal.
Hättest du Unmengen an Kameras, die du ja, die sind ja zentral angeschlossen, dein System müsste pro Sekunde tausende äh hunderttausende Gesichter äh scannen und erkennen,
Ja, das wird es aber je mit jedem Bild nochmal machen. Also du läufst einmal durch den Flughafen, dein Gesicht wird hundert Mal neu gescannt.
Ja gut aber es ist ja nicht so, als als ob da irgendwie jetzt ein fraktal äh Bild ausgerechnet wird, sondern das geht halt relativ schnell.
Weil es sind ja in so einem Flughafen sind ja relativ viele Leute.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, wie viele, wie viele Merkmale deines, ich bin jetzt kein Experte in diesem Bereich, aber Gesichtserkennung, das klingt jetzt,
aufwendig, aber das ist ein gelöstes Problem im Wesentlichen werden Gesichter halt daran erkannt, dass A erstmal merkst, da ist,
Gesicht, das kann heutzutage jedes iPhone, das macht jedes iPhone bei jedem
Foto, was man macht, guckt das Ding ist da ein Gesicht, nicht welches, sondern ist da eins. Die anderen Worte sind immer in der Lage, Nase, Mund, Augen, Abstände zu erfassen in dem Moment und zu sagen, das ist jetzt ein Gesicht, weil das ist innerhalb bestimmter
Bereiche und dann hast du halt einfach ein paar Parameter. Und wenn du jetzt zweihundert Leute suchst
Ich drehe das jetzt halt mal ein bisschen um. Man kann das halt auch so lösen. Dann hast du einfach die Daten dieser gesuchten Leute und die schnell abzugleichen ist äh.
Ist einfach, man da werden nicht viele Zahlen miteinander verglichen.
Das stimmt schon, aber ich bleibe dabei eskaliert besser, wenn du dir dein Ergebnis einmal merkst und
die Leute zum Beispiel in ihren Bewegungen durch den Flughafentracks. Das zu Advice, das was ich gerade mit Kamera eins verglichen habe, hat sich gerade zu Kamera zwei bewegt und ich Kamera zwei sage
O ein Gesicht.
Ja, ich meine, ich, also dieses funktioniert besser,
Ist eine Frage, wie man jetzt besser definiert. Aber ich stimme dir da natürlich zu, dass dass die Logik eines Überwachers auch schnell weggeht von dem wir müssen bestimmte Leute finden, hin, wir müssen bestimmte Verhaltensmuster erkennen.
Vorratszahlenspeicherung. Zack, wir wissen, dass du vor vier Wochen am Flughafen warst.
Ja gut, das ist dann halt die nächste Stufe, aber.
Das ist das ist die Stufe, auf die es hinausläuft. Wenn du hast einmal, du hast erstmal die scheiß Kameras da hängen, dann fängst du an, eine Gesichtserkennung dranzuhängen und dann steht irgendeiner auf und sagt, es kann doch nicht sein, äh dass diese Daten, die wir haben,
nicht auf Ewigkeit gespeichert werden,
Und dann hast du ruckzuck innerhalb von paar Jahren äh eine eine vollständige Gesichtserkennung im öffentlichen Raum inklusive Tracking über.
Ja, sie haben sich doch mit Herrn Meier unterhalten. Wenn wir schon ihre Telefonat, mit Herrn Meier äh festhalten, dann können wir doch auch ihre Privatgespräche mit Herrn Meier als solche natürlich nicht die Inhalte. Wir hören ihnen natürlich nicht zu.
Wir filmen nur ihre Lippen.
Wir wollen nur, wir wollen ja, wenn nur wir merken uns ja nur, dass sie mit ihm gesprochen haben.
Auf jeden Fall ist das ähm,
Was er, was er jetzt so darstellt, als würde man vereinzelte Personen mal äh abgleichen bei Facebook, ja? Äh,
Das ist ja das der Vergleich, den ihr hier anspricht, ne, dass du jemanden fotografierst, das Bild bei Facebook hochlädst und Facebook Tier sagt, hier das ist hier,
Armin Müller, Stahl oder wer auch immer. Gibt's den ja, ne.
Armin Müller-Stahlgips.
Der den Politiker, ne? Nein. Könnte Facebook uns jetzt sagen,
Und äh das was der, was der ähm was der.
Meinst du, Armin Müller startet auf Facebook.
Keine Ahnung,
wahrscheinlich schon, weil Facebook ja Leute, die in Wikipedia-Eintrag haben, zwangs äh importiert. Und deswegen wird der Armin Müller-Stahl wahrscheinlich auf Facebook sein, ob er will oder nicht,
auf jeden Fall, was der Dämme sie erstellt, dass da so da, als als würde ein solches System irgendwie mit sporadischen Erkennungen äh auskommen. Nein, solche Systeme funktionieren dadurch, dass sie auf jeden Fall alle Gesichter immer scannen. Und äh dann ist halt die Frage,
wie lange man das speichert und ob man einfach alle identifiziert oder nur gegen einen Gefährder äh gegen eine Gefährderdatenbank. Und dieses nur gegen eine Gefährderdatenbank ist natürlich das Erste, was fällt,
Und das Ding hast du, wenn du das, wenn du das einmal machst, hast du es innerhalb kürzester Zeit an einem sehr, sehr ekeligen Punkt.
Postet auch selber. Ist auch ein Foto von ihm drauf. Aber das.
Den wir sie ja fragen, ob er das ist. Ja, also da geht's jetzt schon irgendwie in den, in wirklich.
In wirklich üblen in wirklich üblen Bereich, ne? Also wir haben jetzt irgendwie den doch so halbwegs paradoxen Effekt gehabt, dass.
Wie auf einmal digital mehr überwacht wurden als offline und dass es den irgendwie auch aufgefallen.
So übrigens auch dem,
französischen Innenminister Benar Casinov und das hatten wir glaube ich auch in der letzten Sendung schon angekündigt, die haben jetzt ein gemeinsames Eckpunktepackpapier veröffentlicht. Ähm,
äh am Rande des
EU, EU. EU-Ratstreffen für Justiz und Inneres haben sich dann dem Maisier und Casino zusammengesetzt und am einmal so all das Eckpunktpapier,
in sie innere Sicherheit der EU für das,
Q3 zwanzig sechzehn veröffentlicht und da sind so ein paar alte französische Hüte drin wie äh das Passagierdatensystem auch für innereuropäische Flüge anzu,
wenden und das Reiseregister, was ja überhaupt erst noch in Planung ist, dann auch für EU-Staatsangehörige,
anzuwenden und von Deutschland kam dann,
so Ideen wie die Zusammenlegung von Datentöpfen. Die Töpfe müssen zusammengefügt werden, damit sie ein großer Trog werden, an dem die Schweine sich näheren können und äh,
eine Gesichtserkennungsdatenbank, die äh Gesichtserkennungsdatenbanken zu kombinieren mit diesen Datentöpfen. Also alle Daten auf einen Haufen alles miteinander verbinden. Und dann soll doch bitte Europolanschluss an die Systeme bekommen.
Und was ja noch richtig schön wäre, wenn die Direktanfragen von Polizeibehörden.
Nicht immer nur im eigenen Land gingen. Also wenn beispielsweise die deutsche Polizei eine Datenanfrage an einen polnischen Internetprovider stellen könnte,
Und dieser diese Datenanfrage direkt beantwortet würde.
Also quasi, ne, du hast im Moment, kann jetzt die deutsche Polizei bei der deutschen Telekom sagen, gib mal diese Daten, ja? Und wenn.
Ähm die, sage ich, was weiß ich, die die polnische Polizei
an diese Daten möchte, dann muss sie irgendwie mit der deutschen Polizei auf EU-Ebene kooperieren oder mit Europol irgendwie müssen sie dann irgendwie einen Weg finden, da dran zu kommen. Aber De Maizire dachte sie sich, das wäre doch eigentlich super, wenn,
Alle EU, alle Internetprovider der EU-Mitgliedsstaaten, allen Polizeibehörden der EU-Mitgliedsstaaten,
einfach und unbürokratisch Auskünfte erteilen würden.
Und dann hat er sich überlegt, was soll immer dieser Eurozentrismus? Das können wir doch direkt mit der USA, mit den USA auch noch machen.
Hat der Casineff gesagt.
Nee, das ist das, das kam eher aus äh von deutscher Seite. Ja und was aber dann die große, also das sind so die Sachen, die sie jetzt in ihr Eckpunktepapier geschrieben haben und dann machte große Runde, aber die Idee äh dass.
Und das hatten wir auch letzte Woche schon angekündigt, dass ja jetzt der, dass sie jetzt auf WhatsApp und diese ganzen Messenger wollen. Ähm und,
Am Tag nach dieser nach dieser Pressekonferenz und der Veröffentlichung dieses Eckpunktepapiers sagte dann in der Bundespressekonferenz der Sprecher von Thomas Demazier, Johannes Dimmroth,
Wir treten geradezu für gute Verschlüsselungen schwer zu durchbrechende Verschlüsselung ein, um die Datensicherheit der Bürger zu gewährleisten. Wir wollen, um es ganz deutlich zu sagen,
keine Backdoors, wir wollen keine Schlüsselhinterlegung.
Und es würden keine Befugnisse angestrebt, kryptierte Kommunikation abzugreifen, ohne dass wir an die Krypto,
Eckpunkte heran müssten, um unsere grundsätzliche Linie hier,
Und unsere grundsätzliche Linie hier in Frage stellen müssen. Also er sagt ganz klar, wir wollen keinen Direktzugriff auf verschlüsselte, auf Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Kommunikation.
Nicht die Inhalte? Wir wollen.
Wir wollen die Endpunkte hacken.
Also ganz klar, ne? Keine WhatsApp muss keine Baktor einbauen, Signal muss keine Bekauen, unser Ziel ist es, die Zielpersonen zu hacken.
Und der französische Innenminister sagte dann, äh,
unkooperative Anbieter sollten verpflichtet werden, illegale Inhalte zu entfernen oder im Rahmen von Ermittlungen, Nachrichten zu entschlüsseln. So ging der Franzose nach Hause,
aber kein, es genau, es gibt aber kein ähm wortgleiches Dokument, in dem diese Forderung wirklich,
vorkommt. Äh das heißt der der französisch französische Innenministerium verbreitet diese Forderung nach wie vor, aber die gemeinsame Erklärung beinhaltet die Forderung nicht,
Und die deutsche Leitlinie ist äh hängen.
Ja, du musst verstehen, die Franzosen haben einfach große Sorgen, dass dass du deine Daten in so einem Bukini äh durch die Gegend schickst und das ist einfach Datenburkinis verboten.
Dann wo Killies. Ja, das willst du echt nicht haben.
Muss ausgezogen werden, ganz schnell.
Ja, aber ganz interessant, weil das relativ viel äh auf relativ viel für relativ viel Furore sorgte, diese offenkundige äh,
Dieses offgründige Missverständnis, diese Misskommunikation.
Ein vollkommen absurdes Treffen, ja? Also da trifft sich jetzt der Rat weißt schon, der Rat der Europäischen Union, also sozusagen,
klar zu machen, worum es sich dabei handelt, dass es sozusagen das Kollegium der Regierungen Europas, ja, in diesem Fall halt nur Justizinneres, nicht Parlament, Nicht-Kommission,
Und fordert halt einfach mal wieder irgendetwas. Die Frage vor allem wem,
gegenüber fordern sie denn das eigentlich, ja? Also möchten sie jetzt gerne, dass die Kommission entsprechende Maßnahmen äh ergreift, warum machen sie das überhaupt auf EU-Ebene? Ja, also wenn jetzt hier wesentlichen Frankreich und Deutschland,
am Start sind, also das ist ja im Prinzip die Forderung hier irgendeine Art europäische Lösung zu finden, nur dass sie halt,
offenbar überhaupt keinerlei Einigkeit haben darüber, was sie nun eigentlich wollen. Also ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass es alles ein bisschen Dampfplauderei,
Und jeder sagt in seine Kanäle, die Deutschen Richtung Deutschland, die Franzosen in Richtung Frankreich, äh das, was irgendwie gerade ihrer Meinung nach gut klingt.
Also die die Strategie, die beiden unterschiedlichen Strategien sind hier schon
erkennbar, ne? Aber wir kommen gleich nochmal zu der zu der Hacking Strategie der Bundesregierung. Vorher sprechen wir noch ein bisschen über die Nachwehen,
oder nachbeben? Nee, sagen wir mal nach, für ihn ist gerade das Opertunere Wort äh der Landesvorratsaffäre.
Um Netzpolitik Punkt org,
wo uns ja letztes Jahr mit beschäftigen müssen, was auch eine ganze Menge Unterhaltungspotential hatte am Ende, da ja dann das Ganze auch im Wesentlichen ein Rohrkripierer war, äh und am Ende der,
Äh ich war noch sein korrekter Bundesgeneralanwalt Herr Range.
Generalbundesanwalt? General. Bundesgeneralanwalt.
Generalbundes, wie auch immer, also halt,
der muss äh dann ins Heim und äh war so ein bisschen der der Loser und jetzt gibt's so einige neue Erkenntnisse da drüber, wie denn das nun eigentlich wirklich gelaufen ist.
Also eigentlich war es ja so in dem Moment, wo das öffentlich wurde, wollte es ja keiner gewesen sein,
Diese Ermittlungen liefen ja zu dem Zeitpunkt ähm als Markus und Andre darüber in Kenntnis gesetzt wurden schon seit drei Monaten. Und.
Hinter den in diesen drei Monaten hatte der Range ein Gutachten in Auftrag gegeben.
Und der Mars hatte ein eigenes Gutachten erstellen lassen. Das Ergebnis von Maaßens Gutachten,
war, dass die Dokumente, die dort veröffentlicht wurden, keine Staatsgeheimnisse seien,
Und damit auch kein Landesfahrrad erfolgt sei, weil die Dokumente ja nur vertraulich waren,
und nicht geheim. Also kein Landesverrat.
Der Range hatte aber seinen BND-Nahen Gutachter, wo auch wieder klar ist, ne? Wir erinnern uns, der der eigentliche Kläger war ja,
Maaßen vom Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz. Insofern ist klar, dass der natürlich eine Reihe an Gutachtern hat, die,
Ganz spannende Gutachten schreiben können. Wir wissen ja auch, dass Maaßen damals ein sehr schönes Gutachten geschrieben hatte, warum die,
Bundesrepublik Deutschland, Murat Kunas, der in Guantanamo saß nicht mehr zur Hilfe verpflichtet sei, weil ja,
gegen seine Meldeaufpflichten verstoßen hatte in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, weil er in Gontana Mosais. Also wir erinnert's, ich möchte das.
Ja ich kann das nur regelmäßig wiederholen,
Also aus diesem Dunstkreis gab's dann da noch ein Gutachten, was zu einem gegenteiligen Ergebnis kam,
Und ähm dieser Gutachter sagte aber, ja ich bin irgendwie noch nicht so ganz fertig, aber es kann auf jeden Fall sein. Äh ich komme auf jeden Fall zum anderen Ergebnis. Und dann sagte der Range, ich würde jetzt gerne abwarten, bis beide Gutachter fertig sind.
Und dann trat irgendwann der Maß an die Presse und sagte wir sind ja gemeinsam überein gekommen, dass das weitere Gutachten obsolet geworden ist. Das war,
Maßes, Maßins neben,
Heiko Maas seine Aussage und ähm und dann sagte der Range, als er das irgendwie sagt, Saalfern sagt dann, wat.
Nee, gar nicht. Äh haben wir gar nicht gesagt. Ich, ich möchte, ich bleibe dabei,
Und daraufhin gingen dann insgesamt zweiundzwanzig Anzeigen gegen Maß wegen strafvereitelung beziehungsweise Beweismittelunterdrückung ein,
Und diese wurden jetzt verhandelt. Also hat Heiko Maas,
in die Arbeit des Generalbundesanwaltes dort eingegriffen und so letztendlich strafvereignung begangen,
Und das Urteil ist das Maß erstens.
Hier tatsächlich eine Weisung gegeben hat, also das war jetzt sorry, das muss ich noch erklären. Das war der Streitpunkt. Hat Maas,
Den Generalbundesanwalt eine Weisung erteilt, so wie es rangesagt, Range sagt hier, wir sind nicht übereingekommen,
Ich habe hier eine Anweisung erhalten und dann hat Rang ja in seiner äh in seiner Pressekonferenz gesagt, das ist eine Frechheit, dass der Justizminister sich hier einmischt.
Und daraufhin hatte Maas dann gesagt, äh offenbar möchte der Mann äh in den Ruhestand und den Gefallen tue ich ihm jetzt, ja? Aber der Streitpunkte vor Gericht waren also erstens hat Maß eine Weisung, er teilt oder nicht,
Und dann zweitens durfte er diese Weisung erteilen. Oder hat er damit Strafvereidigung begangen?
Ist klar, das eine ist Voraussetzung für das andere, denn wenn die wirklich übereingekommen wären, dann werden sie in zwei, wenn dann beide Strafvereitelungen begangen, aber hätten sie ja in dem Fall eben auch nicht. Also Ergebnis des Gerichtes ist Maaß durfte das,
Es sei von einer im Wege der Weisung durchgesetzten Rechtsauffassung auszugehen. Ähm.
Es habe danach eine die rechtliche Sachbehandlung betreffende Einzelfall
Weisung vorgelegen. Also in diesem Fall hat Maaßen gesagt, Maß gesagt, zu Range hier diesen Fall anders behandeln. Das ist also eine,
Weisung, ja?
Wasser darf eigentlich grundsätzlich Weisungen aussprechen.
Genau.
Weiter sagt das Gericht, die Inanspruchnahme eines Sachverständigen sei nicht geboten gewesen, somit liege in der Anweisung den Gutachter umgehend von seinem Auftrag zu entbinden
Auch kein angeordneter Verzicht auf ein unwiderbringliches Beweismittel,
Mit anderen Worten? Erstens, ja, es war eine Weisung, zweitens, die war aber okay.
Und dann der dritte Punkt durfte er ihn deswegen kicken,
Nun die entsprechende Drohung der Staatssekretärin, so die Staatsanwälte sei keine Nötigung gewesen,
Da sie nicht verwerflich gewesen sei, also es wurde ja komportiert, dass die Staatssekretärin Range gesagt hätte, schönen Job, den sie da haben, wäre doch schade, äh wenn sie den jetzt wegen dieses dämlichen Gutachters äh drangeben müssten.
Ähm das wäre aber nicht verwerflich gewesen, weil das Justizministerium habe eine weitreichende Befugnis, um Generalbundesanwälte zu entlassen. Nach dem Range zu erkennen gegeben hat,
Auf das Ergebnis seines externen Gutachtens nicht zu verzichten.
Musste von einer fehlenden Bereitschaft zu einer künftigen übereinstimmenden Amtsführung ausgegangen werden.
Nachdem er nicht mitspielen wollte, war klar, dass sie ihn feuern müssen. So. Mein Gott, kann dieses Jahr kompliziert.
Interessant ist aber, dass der Mars
öffentlich andauernd behauptet hat, es hätte, es hätte keine Weisung gegeben, das war eben der Streitpunkt. Und jetzt äh schießen sie sich öffentlich nochmal auf den Mars ein, weil jetzt quasi das Gericht gesagt hat, der Mars hat hier eine Weisung erteilt. Maas hat aber,
wiederholt, gesagt, ich habe da keine Weisung erteilt. Und Markus Becke da kommentiert da denke ich sehr gut
Einschießen auf Maß lenken leider von der Verantwortung des Innenministeriums und des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz ab, die die Anzeigen und die Ermittlungen auf den Weg gebracht haben und sich seitdem erfolgreich,
wegbucken. Dem ist nichts. Hinzuzufügen.
Außer, dass ich das grundsätzlich ablehne, dass wir die niedersächsischen Genitive in dieser Sendung verwenden.
Der niedersächsische Genitiv. Die Maßseinen das ist doch nicht Niedersachsen.
Mhm. Das ist doch nicht Niedersachsen. Das ist der niedersächsische Kredit.
Das ist äh da hat es da, also dat haben wir auf jeden Fall im Ruhrgebiet erfunden. Lassen wir uns jetzt nicht auch noch von euch wegnehmen. So. Niedersachsen hier ist ähm an den Marbur.
Vor dem vor dem Hannoveranischen Hauptbahnhof. Steht der gute König Ernst Auges auf seinem Pferd.
Da ist so ein supergeiler Spruch, ne.
Und da liegen dann immer so die Panker da drunter.
Ja, ja, das Foto habe ich letztens gemacht, das habe ich hier oder weil was steht da noch heute.
Und da steht er drüber, dem Landesvater sein treues Volk.
Genau ja, Landesvater sein traues Volk. Das ist super geil. Da standen letztens auch so ein paar Pokemon-Fänger drunter. Weißt du, zwölf Uhr mittags,
auf dem Zahn, nichts zu tun. Pokemons fangen.
Dem Landesvater sein treues Volk, ja das ist ein das ist ein äh das ist ein Motiv äh wie es mir gefällt.
Okay, ich äh ich teil anerkenne äh dass Niedersachsen da auch gut dabei ist.
Gut, gehen wir ins Darknet. Denn äh im Dugnet ist ja alles ganz dunkel und keiner keiner äh kommt klar. Komischerweise kann man trotzdem einfach Leute so ermitteln und festnehmen. Das fand ich doch wirklich sehr erschreckend. Ich dachte immer, dass Darknet Ninos klär mich auf
wäre so ein ähm so ein Bereich, in dem einfach kein Gesetz gilt und dann kannst du machen, was du willst. Also immer wenn immer wenn ich im Darknet bin, dann geht's richtig rund.
Wird die ganze Zeit immer wieder einer rausgezerrt.
Ja, ich dachte, das wäre so ein schwarzes Loch, wo es auch so ein äh so ein so ein Ereignishorizont gibt, aus dem man überhaupt gar nicht rüberkommt, aber trotz alledem scheint es irgendwie möglich zu sein. Da noch was rauszuholen.
Hier haben sie es folgendermaßen gemacht und zwar gab es zwei Ermittlungen oder Ermittlungsverfahren gegen zwei Personen wegen unerlaubten Waffenbesitzes und weiteren Dingen, die sie äh auf die sie irgendwie,
aufmerksam geworden sind, der eine hatte, glaube ich, eine Pistole, der andere hatte ein Gewehr.
Und die Polizei ist derer habhaft geworden und hat gesagt, hör mal, warte denn die Knarren hier, ne? Und dann hat der eine gesagt, hier habe ich Internet, ne? Darknet, ist nicht Internet. So und dann äh hat die,
Polizei ein äh Scheingeschäft mit deren Waffenhändler angebahnt.
Und quasi deren Account, der oder den Account eines dieser Waffenbesitzer genutzt, um ein weiteres Geschäft anzubauen. Und beim Anbahnen dieses Geschäftes,
Hat dann der Händler noch damit angegeben, dass er äh dem,
Typen, der in München rumgeknallt hat, vier Tage vorher die Knarre verkauft hat. Ach, eine Stratege vor dem Herrn, ja, also der weiß, wie man äh,
wie man äh wie man Waffen handelt, ja indem man sich möglichst nochmal mehrfach gegenüber Unbekannten Kunden selbst äh belastet.
Und,
diese diese Behauptung deckte sich halt mit internen Erkenntnissen der äh Staatsanwaltschaft München und des Bayerischen Landeskriminalamtes. Die wussten also, dass mit den vier Tage vorher in Marburg, da wussten die halt, jawohl, das stimmt. Der Typ, der da rumgeballert hat, dieser David
Solowski da wieder heißt, der hatte äh der Wahl in Marburg gewesen, ne? Und ähm.
Da hatten sie glaube ich Records von Busfahrten, ne, mit denen er ist halt, glaube ich, hier so mit Reisebussen hingefahren und äh.
Und dann haben sie auf jeden Fall mit dem Typen mit diesem Waffenhändler gesagt, ja, ist klar, lass mal treffen, machen wir hier, kaufen wir Pistole von dir, treffen uns in Marburg und dann haben sie den Händler selber und eine äh Complete.
Ähm festgenommen und zwar lief das wohl so ab, dass sie sich getroffen haben und dann der
der Händler quasi das Geld entgegennehmen wollte oder entgegengenommen hat und dann die Komplizen irgendwie dann die Ware übergibt. Und die Komplizen haben sie dann auch festgenommen und bei ihr dann auch die Waffe festgestellt und den Personalausweis des Händlers
Und ja, der wird dann jetzt also äh vermutlich einige Zeit nicht mehr im Daten mit sein.
Beziehungsweise in einem anderen Darknet.
Der wird Darknet, Darknet, äh, zwei null äh erleben,
einige Zeit. Also ein ein Vollidiot und da haben wir würde ich sagen, ist ja auch schön, das ist ein Vollidiot war, äh, dass der jetzt,
gefasst wurde. Mit ganz normaler klassischer Polizeiarbeit, wo man auch hier sagen muss, Hut ab, haben sie gut gemacht. Also muss man echt mal sagen, also äh ordentlich in Ruhe das Netz gespannt äh so will man Polizeiarbeit sehen.
Und das ohne Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Und das ohne Vorratsdatenspeicherung, ne? Mehrere Leute mit mit äh wegen unerlaubtem Waffenbesitz ist am Ende im Knast der Waffenhändler im Knast. Äh herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Sogar noch in der Folge noch weitere Leute, die dort Waffen gekauft haben, man weiß es nicht.
Und äh ich darf an dieser Stelle natürlich, wenn ich jetzt schon so viel gelobt habe, auch nicht äh vergessen, dass ich ja genau das auch gesagt habe, dass man so im Darknet äh Leute fängt, indem man eben
in dem Moment, wo die Transaktion zustande kommt, müssen sie ein Teil ihrer Anonymität aufgeben,
und gerade sowas wie eine Waffe, willst du nicht unbedingt mit der Post verschicken? Also trifft man sich. Keyboard und dann,
kriegt man die Handschellen angezogen.
Bayrische Landeskriminalamt hört hier wohl gut zu.
Wenn ihr noch einen Tipp braucht, Jungs.
Wir wissen Bescheid. Äh total fit die Jungs hier.
Dann kommen wir jetzt zu den äh eher kürzeren Meldungen. Wir haben,
Vom CC auf Anfrage der Linksfraktion im Thüringer Landtag nochmal eine kleine äh Stellungnahme zur Quellen-TKÜ,
abgegeben,
Das war also wir wurden hier gebeten zu einem nach um einen Kommentar zur Forderung der Justizministerkonferenz vom Juni zwanzig sechzehn äh wo gefordert wurde,
Den Einsatz der Spionagesoftware auszuweiten und wir haben hier noch einmal, glaube ich, ganz gut dargelegt, warum Quellen TKÜ
nicht geht. Ja, also es gibt ja die Unterscheidung Online-Durchsuchung, okay, einmal den ganzen Computer auseinander nehmen und Quellen TKÜ,
Verschlüsselte Kommunikationsvorgänge. Und als Beispiel, das hatte ich hier glaube ich in der Sendung auch schon mal genannt, haben wir das. Äh Browserfenster genommen, ne, wenn jetzt irgendwie
verschlüsselt über das Browserfenster kommunizierst, dann sieht das für einen Trojaner nicht anders aus, als würdest du irgendeine Webseite besuchen.
Du kannst also keinen maßgeschneiderten Trojaner bauen, der verschlüsselte Kommunikationsvorgänge im Browserfenster abfängt und dabei in null Wahrscheinlichkeit hat,
Andere Sachen mit zu erfassen und gleichzeitig null Wahrscheinlichkeit hat,
Dass ihm verschlüsselte Kommunikationsvorgänge entgehen und so wie eine Quellen-TKÜ aufgebaut wird, ist natürlich, dass du sagst, okay, wir verzichten auf.
Spezifität zugunsten von Sensitivität, das heißt, wir wollen, wir erfassen lieber mehr als zu wenig und das ist eben das inherente Problem.
Der QuellentKÜ. Das kann man sich nochmal anschauen. Ähm, das steht jetzt auch nichts unbedingt neues drin, aber wir haben dann mal wieder ein bisschen,
was formuliert,
unseren unsere Meinung dazu gegeben. Interessanterweise war der Artikel genau ein Tag oder der Artikel, die Stellungnahme, genau ein oder zwei Tage fertig, bevor bei Netzwerk orke dann wieder rauskam, dass,
dass das BKA auch wieder auch gleichzeitig mit Gamma kooperiert, also zwei Staatstrojaner hat, deswegen findet sich in der Stellungnahme auch noch das Argument, dass,
Du ja mit dem Einsatz deiner.
Also dass du quasi mit jedem Einsatz des Staatstrojaners das Problem eingehst oder das Risiko eingehst, alle Ermittlungsverfahren, in denen der zum Einsatz kommt, zu gefährden. Das,
ist durch diese Kooperation mit Gamma nicht weg, dieses Problem, aber da haben sie quasi durch zwei Staatstrojaner im Prinzip schon so eine Art
Kontingenzplan, ne? Also wenn der CCC mal wieder einen von unseren Staatstrianern hochgehen lässt, dann äh drücken wir auf den roten Knopf und äh sallen um.
So die äh Theorie der Angreifer in diesem Fall.
Zum Schluss.
Zum Schluss haben wir noch eine schöne Veröffentlichung von Nexus vom CC Hannover. Der hat sich den äh Bub Con Messenger angeguckt. Ein waren wir auch nicht bekannt. Gibt's auch erst seit ein paar Tagen,
Er soll, also ist mal wieder ein Ende zu Ende verschlüsselter Messenger und äh der wird also sehr,
vollmundig angekündigt.
Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt und so weiter, hier toller Messenger und ähm Nextus hat sich das mal angeschaut, hat da einen sehr schönen Artikel zugeschrieben, haben wir auch verlinkt. Ähm.
Im Prinzip ist es zwar also erstens, der ist nicht Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt. Das ist ganz normales äh normales XMP, also Jabba mit einer Transportverschlüsselung. Also es gibt einfach keine Ende zur Ende Verschlüsselung in.
Und nur deutsche Server.
Nur deutsche Server war aber alles irgendwie Amazon Cloud und also jedes Versprechen, was sie machen, ist irgendwie nachweislich äh falsch
Und dann hat er noch irgendwie gesehen, dass sie halt irgendwie ein ein komisches, selbst signiertes Zertifikat für diesen Server benutzen, das auch nicht pinnen, das heißt, jeder kann einfach mit jedem Zertifikat dazwischen
und dann hat gestern Abend noch jemand das Zertifikat auf Gitter gefunden. Das heißt.
Äh das war irgendwie das Standardzertifikat, was,
Sampels von irgend so einer Open Source Implementierung von einem Jabba-Server äh drin lag. Also das Ding ist von vorne bis hinten wirklich kaputt.
Ähm und äh Amazon hat also Vollzugriff auf die übermittelten Inhalte. Das Ding ist nicht Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt
der der Registrierungsvorgang ist kaputt. Also einmal
alles, alles falsch gemacht, was man machen kann und die werben dann halt irgendwie groß damit und er hat irgendwie im weiteren Verlauf dann auch noch einer deren Webseite gehackt und ähm
an alle Nutzer eine Mail geschrieben mit Hinweis auf diese Analyse von Nexus,
Und dann haben sie irgendwie jetzt so eine Facebook äh Seite geschrieben, wo sie sagten, ja unser Server wurde gehackt, ist aber kein Problem. Update einfach die App,
Was also auch wieder so ist falsch, falsch Unsinn und es ist einfach alles,
Es ist so eine richtige richtig richtige,
Üble Mogelpackung, jetzt schreiben sie irgendwie hin so ja äh zur Zeit ist die Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung aufgrund technischer Schwierigkeiten inaktiv ähm aber das Ding wird halt als als
Ende zu Ende verschlüsselter Messenger angeboten, äh ein ja, aber da haben wir mal äh hat ähm.
Bullshit Made in Germany.
Da haben wir mal wieder so richtig schön Bullshit Made in Germany und äh das ist also H.
Haarsträubend, was da alles gefunden wurde. Das ist so richtig, richtig kaputt alles. Kann man nur wirklich die Finger von lassen. Das ist ein,
riesiges also wenn man da nur der hat jetzt noch nicht mal groß angefangen zu hacken, der hat ja nur irgendwie so die die Basalen Angriffe und das Ding zerbrach schon unter seinen Fingern,
Ähm und dann eben das das Zertifikat mit Private Key of Gitterp aus ihnen zum Standardrepo Junge Junge. Also das ist äh,
Da musst du schon richtig wenig Ahnung haben, um um diese Fehler zu machen. Da, also den sollte man sich wirklich nicht anvertrauen.
Der Gemeinde Bernd hat unseren Server gehackt. Schreiben sie.
Ja das war ja dann irgendjemand anders, damit hat ja der CSC nichts zu tun.
Es verbernt.
Das war Bär, ja, ich weiß auch wo Bernd wo.
Ja, weißt wo Bernd Wut,
sie möchten den Gemeinden werden, möchten sie Zukunft bitten, sich doch wieder intensiv um Rni zu kümmern. Was auch immer jetzt Bernd mit Erni.
Ich glaube, sie wollten da halt.
Haben da nicht mal die Sesamstraße verstanden. Ja.
Aber wenn.
Strebendes Start-up. Na ja, das ist aufstrebendes Start-up scheint im Wesentlichen äh Marketinggetrieben zu sein und äh ansonsten von der Materie nicht,
entweder nichts zu verstehen oder das nicht als äh wichtig ansehen, dann damit aber dann gleichzeitig zu werben ist schon so ein bisschen, na ja.
Es ist offiziell, wir hatten den ersten Hackerangriff der Gemeinde Bernd
Siehe Foto, da sind Foto von Sesamstraße Bären, hat gestern unseren Server gehackt und heute eine Rundmail an die Bookcom Community
versendet. Ja, na ja, also okay, das ist also Finger von dem Ding, das ist wirklich äh
Bauanfängerei, was da stattfindet. Und äh man es wird auch kolportiert ähm im Darknet,
Dass das Ding auch jetzt nicht so viele Nutzer hatte.
Nee, das ist ja auch jetzt gerade mal erst seit einer Woche da.
Wird auch hoffentlich dann in einer Woche weg sein, weil das schon wirklich äh refallig ist, was da passiert. Ja.
Tja. Das bringt uns zum Ende der Sendung.
Bringt uns zum Ende der Sendung. Ich freue mich auf die nächste, nächste Sendung wird dann so eine richtige Depressionssendung oder nochmal.
Deswegen nimmst du auch gleich die Beine in die Hand und bist nicht dabei.
Deswegen nehme ich mir oft frei.
Genau, dann werden wir mal diese ganze äh Innen und äh Europapolitischen Maßnahmen nochmal ein bisschen in Kontext betrachten,
Ja und ansonsten gilt es noch so ein bisschen hier den August noch zu genießen. Wetter passt ja. Ich hoffe, ihr liegt alle am Strand, während ihr das hört.
Ja
Ach so, hier, ich habe noch eine äh eine Sache bekannt zu geben. Und zwar gibt es einige sehr wenige äh und sehr freundliche LNP-Hörer und Hörerinnen, die auf ein Konto von mir,
Daueraufträge eingerichtet haben. Ja,
Und ähm dieses Konto wird irgendwann im Oktober aufhören zu existieren. Ich habe aber noch keinen Ersatz dafür, aber ihr könnt also quasi schon.
Können Mainz nehmen, solange.
Ich ich das äh.
So war das ja noch nicht gemein.
Richtet euch mal darauf ein, dass irgendwie ab Oktober oder November diese ähm diese Aufträge platzen werden,
Und dann könnt ihr natürlich entweder das steht euch frei bei äh nicht Gefallen
könnt danke ich euch dann, wenn ihr den Auftrag dann äh beendet entsprechend und bin euch für die Unterstützung dankbar. Ansonsten werde ich zeitnah ein neues Konto einrichten und dann
euch
dieses Anbieten, wenn ihr das weitermachen möchtet. Da freue ich mich natürlich drüber, wenn ihr es weitermachen wollt. Aber die Kontonummer wird sich in absehbarer Zeit,
ändern.
Tim bleibt äh von meiner Seite her nichts äh hinzuzufügen.
Von meiner Seite auch nicht.
Gut, dann machen wir das Schluss. Dann tschüss. Ja. Okay. Ciao.
Ja, okay. Tschüss.